hey youtubers is Charlie this week on
Teen Wolf they paid off the young Derek
plot as well as tease the main villain
to season forth the benefactor there
were a few funny moments but the Cate
story ended up turning into something
totally different before we get started
though hello to any new people who are
just finding me for the first time I'm
gonna be doing weekly Teen Wolf videos
for each episode be sure to subscribe to
get everything
I'm even gonna try to do some bonus
videos too so feel free to leave me
suggestions for like Teen Wolf lore
topics to do so it was really glad that
they resolved the big mystery of young
Derek from episode 1 but because the
real story was something totally
different we're gonna need to spend most
of our time talking about that so what
I'm going to do is my top 5 moments then
a quick breakdown of that new character
that they introduced the benefactor and
talked about what he's going to be doing
this season and then my overall review
so careful for spoilers from the episode
if you haven't seen it yet I'll wait a
couple seconds everybody ready ok here
we go number 5
Malia meets Peter so in case you missed
it last season Malia is Peters
biological daughter her mother was mrs.
Tate married to mr. Tate her mother just
had an affair with Peter but she was
raised as mr. Tate's daughter everyone
thought she died but then in season 3
she appeared after living as a coyote
for years cutting out where she's
failing it history class in the most
adorable way possible trying to learn
how to be human again her meeting Peter
was huge though Peter knew exactly who
she was but she still doesn't know that
he's her father so traveling back to a
little bit earlier in the episode
remember when Scott was telling stiles
that truth was always the best route to
take I feel like them not telling Malia
that Peter's her father is gonna
literally bite them in the ass later
this season I mean she would probably
bite someone in the ass I felt like I
saw some Peter vibes coming off Malia
though it was a lot of fun she's got a
lot of his rage and impulsiveness
Peter's a little bit more subtle you
know just having the benefit of a couple
years of experience but I can totally
see his subconscious presence inside of
her not like whenever he was controlling
Lydia but just shades of him behind her
eyes I feel like there's a high
likelihood that because of that
connection she'll betray the pact for
Peter whenever she does learn the truth
I think that Stiles is like her anchor
to the real world so if she were ever
forced to choose between Peter in the
pack I think that you know the outcome
would depend a lot on her relationship
with Stiles at the moment it would be
fun to see Stiles try and win her back
doesn't it kind of seem like anyone
associated with the Hale family gets
tied up in a betrayal plot sooner or
later even Derek who was BFFs with Scott
last season had been an antagonist
before that so definitely a high
probability of Malia flip-flopping this
season number four Kate wants to learn
to control her shifting it was a little
confusing kate was being manipulated
just like she was manipulating young
Derek she really did want the Triskelion
so she could control her shifting and
yes I do think she'll listen to Peter's
advice and figure it out on her own
eventually it's actually been a while
since I've thought about that symbol on
Teen Wolf so whenever I heard Peter call
it out I thought of the Triskelion on
Marvel's agents of shield on that show
it's basically a large base that also
doubles as a prison for supervillains
the Hale family's Triskelion means a
bunch of different things usually each
time it shows up like in season 1 season
2 season 3 it's a metaphor for something
different in Greek in Celtic mythology
it typically represents the stages of
life like birth life death in the stages
of the Moon new half full in this
episode for Derek and Kate I think it
just represented past present and future
just because of their previous
relationship and Derek's physical
transformation you know he literally had
gone into the past for Peter and Malia I
think it represented mother father
daughter you know it's all about
progression family relationships which
is basically what this episode was
foreshadowing you know a lot of the
future relationships and the inner group
dynamics number three Lydia's powers
start to manifest more so Lydia's
spacing out into banshee mode and
finding the murder scene is going to
keep happening until she learns to
control her powers just like Kate's
trying to learn to control her shifts
it's like they're on the same path
they're trying to master their two
states of existence you know
supernatural and natural I like that
they used the cell phone pictures for
comedy
it wouldn't be Lydia they didn't try to
make a joke out of it I feel like her
comedic powers actually exists in direct
relationship with her proximity to
Stiles you know the closer they drift
together the funnier it gets but I
cannot imagine how sticky that bathroom
got after they filmed that scene and
some of the trailers we actually saw
scenes of Lydia investigating other
murders so this idea goes into the
benefactor and the Deadpool list which
I'll totally explain in a second but
there gonna be a lot of serial killings
going on for Lydia it's gonna be like
moth to flame until she learns to
control her powers she's gonna keep
spacing out and showing up at dead
bodies I like that they used the
bathroom for this first big kill in this
episode
I kind of thought it was a callback to
the bathroom in episode 1 the one that
Kate refused to kill herself in that
also kind of becomes a callback to the
Calaveras because I feel like they're
gonna come on the show pretty soon too
number 2 young Derek transforms back
into old Derek so this was another logic
jump the show is asking you to make but
remember he was transforming back while
he was going apeshit on the berserkers
who knew that young Derek was so good at
Krav Maga and parkour this was all
happening while Peter was explaining how
to use anger to control shifting it made
me think that young Derek just trapped
into some sort of primal rage and that's
what caused him to revert back to normal
the only issue I had with this was that
they didn't really explain the mechanics
of young Derek really well like what
kind of spell did Kate use to make his
body and mine revert to a younger state
and if young Derek could transform into
old Derek using raw emotion how come old
Derek couldn't do the same thing in
Reverse feel free to write your theories
about that in the comments below but I
feel like whenever Stiles dad was
freaking out about it it was just the
writers telling us the viewers not to
try and poke too many holes in it and my
number one moment the benefactor reveals
himself it's a bit of a deus ex mashing
up but the person at the end is the
benefactor he's the main villain this
season and the one who used Kate to get
the bear bonds so there were all kinds
of questions that popped up in those
last couple of minutes but I have a few
theories about why he stole that money
creator Jeff Davis was talking about the
idea of the Deadpool list this season
it's a kill list of all the supernatural
creatures living in Beacon Hill's
the benefactor is behind it or will be
behind it and I think he's going to use
those bear bonds to finance the kills
whenever someone kills the name on the
list he has to pay them a lot of money
so that has to come from somewhere Josef
GATT is the actor listed as playing the
benefactor on IMDB in case you didn't
see it he played a wart on Game of
Thrones season 4 you can't tell from
this picture but he is super huge like
as big as one of those berserkers so
it's totally unclear why he wants to
kill all the supernatural creatures in
beacon hills but it does allow us to
eliminate some familiar villain faces
like Peter for instance it seemed like
he genuinely flipped out whatever that
money was stolen wouldn't it be crazy if
this was like usual suspects and he was
just a verbal Kint like the Kevin Spacey
character that secretly turned out to be
Keyser söze and just be behind
everything I don't think that's what's
going on but I do like the idea of Peter
being the Loki of the series you know
the constant
trickster you can never trust your ears
or your eyes whenever he's around he's
always working some sort of long con to
regain alpha status remember his eyes
still glow blue not alpha red so now
it's your turn let me know in the
comments below what was your favorite
moment and why do you think the
benefactor wants to kill all the
supernatural creatures and do you think
that it's going to cause some sort of
mega alliance to form you have to
remember that there's a lot more than
werewolves in beacon hills so real quick
here's a couple things that I thought
were really important but didn't
necessarily make it into my top 5 first
off the pairings I love the way that
they mixed and matched characters from
last episode last week it was Kieran
Malia this week we saw Kira go off with
Lydia and I really liked the way pairing
people brings unexpected energy like
whenever Malia went off with Scott and
then Peter had what was probably the
funniest line of the episode we're not
exactly a brain trusted geniuses here so
you wouldn't get that if Stiles had gone
off with Scott because he is the genius
I'm really looking forward to more Malia
Peter scenes we still need to see Stiles
and cure it get some moments actually I
take that all back Malia and Lydia are
who I want to see together next they can
go all scooby-doo on a crime scene
together the Kira Scott relationship is
developing it's probably to take the
longest to go anywhere but I do think it
will go somewhere million styles are
definitely a thing and Stiles and Lydia
are like the sexless old couple to just
crack jokes or maybe like buddy cops
that have an unconsummated relationship
I do feel like Stiles and Lydia would
make a great true detective season 2
after the last couple of episodes
Malia's become my favorite character
she's got all the right qualities to
kick butt while getting herself into a
hilarious situations and stay adorable
while she's making a mess of things like
history class for instance she's like a
puppy and you cannot get mad at a puppy
Scott still on the path to becoming a
leader even though he's a true alpha the
whole history speech about great leaders
failing greatly was foreshadowing for
him it's not really a spoiler since Jeff
Davis explained the new character Liam
but Scott's gonna have a beta pretty
soon so I don't know the circumstances
around Scott creating a new werewolf
creating the beta but remember what the
Calaveras said the minute he turned
someone else and made a new werewolf
they'd come for him so eventually
they'll show up for better or worse
hopefully they'll help out with Kate
while they're there so overall I thought
the episode was a solid b-plus did a
good job of wrapping up the Derek plot
even though it defied a little bit
logic and it set up a lot of what the
group dynamics and character arts are
going to be going forward we have
Detective ban Chi failed leader made
stronger by the experience and a lot of
romantic ships we also still need to
meet those new freshmen characters the
lacrosse players that's probably gonna
happen in Episode three but in the
meantime I'm going to be doing a bonus
video for next Monday be sure to
subscribe to get it
it's gonna be like a bonus lore video
for the Triskelion for like the history
the Triskelion the Greek and Celtic
mythology but feel free to leave me a
suggestion for another topic right now
then click here to get my review of
episode one angle here to get my
personal Q&A I actually did a bunch of
personal questions that you guys asked
me at VidCon it was a lot of fun thanks
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tomorrow
high fives
you